[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís o de
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español méxico destaca en el mundo
por los elevados niveles de impunidad y
ausencia de justicia que caracterizan
los crímenes y desapariciones forzadas
de decenas de miles de personas
producidas estos últimos años los
gobiernos de alemania y francia- otorgan
cada año el premio franco-alemán de
derechos humanos gilberto bosques dicho
premio este año ha sido concedido al
movimiento por nuestros desaparecidos
que reúne 72 colectivos distribuidos en
mexico de búsqueda de desaparecidos
saludamos en nuestro estudio a diana
iris miembros del colectivo fuerzas
unidas por nuestros desaparecidos en
coahuila y méxico bienvenida de análisis
a esta escala en parís buenos días y
gracias por este espacio que nos permite
visibilizar lo que estamos haciendo en
esa visita gracias a usted por
acompañarnos el movimiento por nuestros
desaparecidos de méxico acaba de obtener
este galardón del premio gilberto
bosques que representa para ustedes este
reconocimiento bueno como bien dijiste
este movimiento nacional por nuestros
desaparecidos en méxico nos ha
organizado a muchas familias para exigir
y demandar haciendo fuerza unida iu este
premio puede nos da mucho gusto que ya
nos hayamos sido
otorgado por el gobierno franco alemán
porque además de visibilizar y de
cobertura a las familias y al movimiento
nos nos permiten elevar nuestra voz con
la comunidad europea el colectivo del
que ustedes hacen parte logró que se
aprobase la ley sobre desaparecidos en
2017 después de una batalla monumental
que es lo que implica esta ley y cuáles
son los problemas que han encontrado
para su correcta aplicación diana y
bueno esta ley significa mucho para las
familias porque había sido la
recomendación de organismos
internacionales como la onu siempre
había
recomendado a mexico legislar en materia
de desaparición y nos da la aceptación
del gobierno mexicano de que hay
desapariciones en él
además con esta ley nos permite exigir
en cada entidad federativa que se
homologuen leyes locales a nivel de esta
ley general que nos da las herramientas
para poder exigir más con más fuerza y
con el poder legislativo que nos provee
las personas que forman estos colectivos
evidentemente se han sometido a una
doble pena si se puede decir así por un
lado la pérdida de un ser querido pero
además los riesgos que implique implica
el ponerse a buscar estas personas que a
veces son perseguidas que les cuál es la
experiencia que usted nos puede dar en
este terreno bueno para empezar las
familias nos sometemos a una especie de
tortura porque la desaparición es un
delito que ésta se tiene la historia que
es para infundir terror porque no se
sabe de la persona que está desaparecida
no se sabe si vive o muere
y es una constante incertidumbre cada
día que pasa es vital para nosotros no
entonces el riesgo es mayor porque el
gobierno del estado mexicano se encarga
de criminalizar y estigmatizar a las
familias a las personas que están
desaparecidos
estamos en constante es una tortura cada
vez que nos dice a las madres sobre todo
y a las mujeres que estamos llevando a
cabo esta lucha que en la mayoría somos
mujeres y siempre nos dicen pero a las
madres en este caso como es mi
experiencia
nos han llegado a decir que nosotros no
los educamos bien y que los
desaparecidos andaban metidos en 'la
usted precisamente lo comentaba usted es
la madre de daniel
y canto iris desaparecido en 2007 en
coahuila que pasó cuáles son los
resultados que estén obtenido después de
tantos años de desaparición de su hijo
daniel cantú iris como bien dices
desapareció en 2007 el próximo año en
febrero ya son 15 años sin saber de él
es una de las desapariciones que se
empezaron a dar en honores en nuestro
país
realizado por [__] federal pues 6
es sufrir la desaparición de mi hijo ha
sido devastador primero porque el fiscal
general nos decía que estaba metido en
algo que si no traía dinero demás
1 las familias no saben de qué se tratan
al principio qué es lo que pasó que es
una desaparición sin embargo por la
necesidad de exigir verdad y justicia
hemos tenido que capacitarnos en muchas
disciplinas lo que pasó con mi hijo en
coahuila las desapariciones tienen
un punto en especial todas sobre todo en
el colectivo de fundec en fuerzas unidas
por nuestros desaparecidos en coahuila y
en mexico el perfil es que la mayoría de
su nombre y sus desapariciones fueron en
tránsito y colectivas más de uno o muy
pocas una sola persona pasaban en
tránsito por trabajo o por diversión por
el estado de caudillo y fueron
desaparecido los contextos son
diferentes a lo largo y ancho del país
pero al fin acabó el delito de
desaparición es contemplado con la
impunidad del estado como un delito de
lesa humanidad
hay que saber que coahuila queda en el
norte de méxico es un país que tiene 32
estados cifras oficiales hablan de más
de 90 mil desaparecidos después del 2006
a este propósito odian a iris como nace
fuerzas unidas por nuestros
desaparecidos en coahuila y méxico
nací en el dow en diciembre de 2009
como un pilar especial la iglesia tuvo
que ver mucho porque nos acogió y de
esta manera nos fuimos organizando antes
para entender lo que pasó con nuestros
familiares para entender cómo teníamos
que denunciar y exigir que se les
buscará y que se les encontrara sabemos
que es uno de los colectivos que tienen
más tiempo organizado sin embargo vimos
con el paso del tiempo que la de las
desapariciones se fueron dando en todo
el país y como lo emitió el grupo de
trabajo de naciones unidas ya él también
lo admitió en forma no oficial el comité
contra las desapariciones forzadas que
terminó su visita en méxico el pasado 26
de noviembre apenas pero declaró que las
desapariciones en méxico son
generalizadas esto que quiere decir que
se desarrollan a lo largo y ancho del
país ya nadie la crisis de los
desaparecidos en méxico surge en el año
2006 con la presidencia felipe calderón
hizo esta llamada guerra contra el narco
se ha acentuado con el paso de los años
que evaluación hacen ustedes con
respecto a la política del actual
gobierno dirigido por el presidente
lópez obrador en la materia de búsqueda
de desaparecidos y sobre todo también de
dar justicia en estos casos de hacer
justicia en estos casos bueno solo hacer
la aclaración que en méxico hay
desapariciones de la mal llamada guerra
sucia de los 70 en los años 70 que
también éste siguen desaparecidos de
igual manera eran este el perfil era
diferente eran activistas sociales sin
embargo como bien dices desde 2006 se
inicia esta fallida guerra contra el
narcotráfico la militarización en las
calles que también dio pie a la mayoría
de las desapariciones y mucha
inseguridad si bien es cierto se inicia
ahí creemos que las prácticas fueron mal
aplicadas sobre todo mandar a los
militares a las calles que no ellos
estaban preparados para otra cosa para
la guerra y no para la protección de las
de la sociedad en general
este perdón que la pregunta es qué
evaluación hace con respecto a la
política del gobierno sabiendo que
precisamente el presidente lópez obrador
también ha decidido de mantener las
fuerzas armadas en la calle y de llevar
esta guerra contra el narcotráfico si
bien es cierto antes cuando ya había
sido electo el presidente actual nos
reunimos con él antes de que tomara
cargo y él dijo que su prioridad en su
administración iban a ser las personas
desaparecidas y que no había no no iba a
haber este techo para los recursos para
que se dieran se encontrarán a las
personas yo sigo así sin embargo a eso
voy este su discurso más fue más de
mediático y político que nada porque
vamos a la mitad de su administración
y si bien reconocemos que se se ha
aceptado que las desapariciones en
méxico el número de desaparecidos en
méxico como bien dijiste 94 mil personas
desaparecidas y lo reconocieron y han
hecho
algunas cosas no ha sido suficiente para
realmente en su discurso mediático dijo
que iba a dar todo no su prioridad sin
embargo creemos que ante esta cifra y
ante los 52 mil personas que están sin
vida en algunos semáforos y demás
reconocemos que es una gran son cifras
de horror no son tormentos 94 mil 52 mil
que se deberían hacer prácticas más
extraordinarias porque esto no es
ordinario sin embargo se quiere resolver
de la manera como si fueran menos
personas y creemos las familias que no
se han hecho los esfuerzos suficientes
para darle a la sociedad mexicana
justicia verdad y memoria para afrontar
este tipo de desapariciones como
personas que son no como un simple
número
exactamente sin embargo aunque en el
área en la parte legislativa se ha
avanzado
tenemos la ley general como habíamos
comentado tenemos protocolos de búsqueda
sin embargo la fiscalía general de la
república ha obstaculizado y ha dicho
que a partir de la ley general se va a
dedicar a la investigación de los hechos
y se niega a dar el reconocimiento a ser
buscado de las personas desapareció ya
se sabe o se ha dicho que muchos de los
desaparecidos han fallecido sin embargo
sabemos también que hay testimonios de
gente que ha reaparecido y que han
testimoniado de que fuera un objeto de
secuestro y de ser obligados a trabajos
forzados que sabe usted de colectivo a
propósito de esto y sobre todo cuáles
son hoy en día las regiones con las
zonas si se puede hablar en estos
términos más peligrosas en méxico en
términos de desapariciones
esta comparativa y este hecho tan
nefasto de publicar que las personas
desaparecidas pudieran estar muertas o
pudieran estar sin un corazón que late
ha sido un discurso mediático
porque nosotros las familias de todo el
país siempre nuestra demanda principal
es un eje de vida una búsqueda en vida
porque vivo se los llevaron vivos los
queremos sin embargo por eso le comenta
a usted que ha sido un discurso
mediático porque quieren decir que con
52 mil personas que están sin vida sin
identificar que son 52 mil personas
desaparecidas si bien es cierto que son
cuerpos de personas que tienen familia
que también los deben estar buscando no
puede decir que ahí están todos los
desaparecidos porque porque nosotros
exigimos una investigación
para dar con ellos como sea pero siempre
vuelvo a repetir con un eje de vida una
búsqueda en bing pues esperamos que con
esta presencia que nuestros estudios
esto les permita a ustedes avanzar en
esta lucha precisamente por la
reaparición de estas personas que han
sido desaparecidas sus seres queridos
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís agradecemos a diana iris
su presencia en nuestros estudios yo
recuerdo ustedes miembros del colectivo
fuerzas unidas por nuestros
desaparecidos en coahuila y méxico
gracias por habernos acompañado y anaïs
y aquí les quedamos con ustedes les
damos una nueva cita la próxima semana
en otra escala en parís
[Música]